hi everyone can you hear me okay
wonderful uh I'm Shafi Goldwater I'm the
director of the Simons Institute for
theory of computing and uh some of you I
know I've been here I'm not sure
everyone so I just say a few words about
um about us
hi everyone
um so just tell you a few words about
the Science Institute we were uh
established in 2012 so it's um
essentially a decade ago and uh it was
due to a very generous gift from the
Simons Foundation that's recognized the
importance of bringing together uh the
world's
leading uh researchers and postdocs to
study aspects of foundations of computer
science
and which we usually call Related
theoretical pure science but with a big
emphasis on related fields from The
Sciences whether it's economics or
biology or physics and engineering and
um the private the primary aim really is
for you to get together and work and
collaborate and sort of dig deep
and uh in particular your Workshop is on
the information theoretic methods for
um
trustworthy machine learning so
trustworthy now is becoming a very
common use words but when this
conference was established maybe less so
it's moving extremely rapidly and uh I
would like to thank the organizers for
their work in putting together this
great program very interesting a lot and
I think they're all here right Elita a
Sankar from Arizona State University a
Flavio from Harvard which I remember
from his days is a PhD student at MIT
Oliver a crossword uh hi Oliver there
you are uh you want to collapse with
them
organizing the workshop and uh just as
just a few Logistics that I'd like to
cover a food is um prohibited in the
auditorium and so is a drink besides
water and uh there's you know
Refreshments provided there's a
reception at the end of the day today
but luncheon your own there are a few
large places around here and there's a
business school across the street
there's a law school there's rice and
bones and then there's a bankrupt and
our videographer is Omid who's sitting
over there in that room and he's very
attentive there's any kind of problem
just go to you know just kind of flag
him and he will come in but he probably
notices it before you do the workshop is
uh hybrid which means that it's both in
person but it's also being streamed and
um
you can ask I guess q and A's also if
you're online I think you could just
sort of speak up and then uh we will
hear you
um the organizer we have an event person
Elizabeth un is Elizabeth here sometimes
she speaks in the beginning
um so she is managing the logistic for
this week so you should ask her any
questions about events or accommodations
and
um now I'll hand over things to you and
thanks again thank you
thank you
I just want to say a couple of things
before we get started with our awesome
Clarity speakers
um we should thank the NSF uh five years
back he wrote this proposal uh on
privacy and the age of learning and very
much in the age of learning right and we
as a nature of medium proposals to the
NSF we had to do a uh broadening
participation in Computing and we wanted
to do a workshop like this and we really
want to thank the Simon's Foundation
because I was here in 2019 just after we
submitted this proposal for the Privacy
uh workshop and some of you here were
there too and uh the seminar for a whole
semester and that was amazing and I'm so
glad your team helped us so much to get
this going we could have done it ASU but
this is this is
um we have a wonderful set of speakers
for four days we were going to do three
days but thanks to all of you we had a
lot of speakers amazing keynote there's
diversity speakers the person who talks
but at all on the topic of information
theoretic methods for machine learning
or
trustworthy reliable Burgers
um so our first
keynote speaker is Professor Clara
javidi from the University of California
San Diego
um we all know her in the information
for the community I could go on and on
about her I'm going to leave you with
one idea what she's doing now she's the
second
um editor-in-chief for the journal
for a special selected area selected
areas of information Theory
um
second woman in our community to be uh
and um and she's also going to talk
about that and uh with some ideas
hopefully there's a lot of things that
come out of this and maybe the ghosts
are in that direction so without further
Ado I'm gonna let Tara
[Applause]
so it's so nice to be here
um I don't think I've given a talk to so
many friends and many people who
variously have to be motivated this work
so
um some of you some of you I will
mention some uh have contributed in Long
discussions and and I'll try to uh uh do
this but um the the pitch that lalito is
talking about is as the assistant chief
of Jay State have tried different ways
the classic way that that the journal
has been run that we passed you
individually and think you know can you
lead a special issue but I was thinking
this Workshop will be a very nice place
maybe to do it more collaboratively
um we think about putting together a
sort of a tutorial or uh invited survey
paper but definitely I hope by the end
of the week all the lunch and dinner
times you can write a few lines that at
least we will have a call for a special
issue with the organizer with the three
of them uh hopefully have a reasonable
date we are going to a volume only so we
need to do a lot of advertisement and so
on and so forth to get a good setup and
this is of course a very very good topic
I am not the best person to open a
workshop on trustworthy ammo I'm going
to talk about IC methods but my
definition of trustworthy is it's you
know I can explain it so you know it's a
little bit more rigorous in terms of the
proofs and and such so bear with me
um
and I I'm gonna use Prezi and this is
the first place I have to acknowledge uh
Anan was the one who told me about this
and I have been giving my talk soon uh
in the software so
um that's the first announcement of
contributions so let me just um
okay so
um
where information theorists then you say
Ai and machine learning optimization and
it's easy to argue at the end of the day
it's making sense of data and we are
working on the science of making sense
of data so there should be some close uh
connections and I'm sure everybody today
and the rest of the week will talk about
this
um what I have been interested in is in
many practical or engineering settings
um the data can be controlled what data
to con to collect even whether this is
in the training phase for example
medical image labeling and so on or in
the runtime right with sensors to turn
on and off and then this I want to argue
with that feedback information Theory
can help quite a bit
um so um so I'm going to talk about some
of the methods the way I teach
information Theory these days using
feedback information Theory which makes
it very nice to do ml so let me just
show you the examples I'm not going to
be able I promise the Lalita that I
won't do enough math so I can't be too
superficial but let me just show off
that I can
um from like very practical problems
let's say you have a drone and this is
something my lab we have done
um you have a drone and you want to
track a moving object let's say on on a
you know Court like this the basketball
and the drones flight uh height will
determine the quality of the images that
you collect right so here I would argue
that in the runtime where the Drone is
you know trying to infer and track this
object the kind of pictures you take are
going to be very different and that will
determine the quality of decision making
that you will make right
um all the way in in Wireless com for
aligning uh transmitters and receivers
um Active Learning uh and some
networking application that I will talk
a little bit more about
um you will have this notion that you
can collect data in some orchestrated
way and do uh you know sort of the
classic statistical learning tasks so
the problem mathematically uh is is
fairly simple to State this is the
dynamic version of the problem I have a
hidden stochastic process that I am
interested in use using this whether
this is um the the location of the
transmitter and as the receiver I'm
interested in aligning my my beam
forming Vector with that or it could be
the location of the basketball or
whatnot and I'm interested in estimating
this process through noisy observations
um and then there's these sequence of
actions that make the problem active in
incense so by orchestrating the sequence
of action I'm controlling the
conditional observation of Y given what
Theta is
so for the purpose of this talk maybe
make it even simpler maybe this
stochastic process is even markovian and
simpler
but the it boils down to minimizing
something like a cumulative loss of
comparing your estimates plus some costs
associated with taking these actions
so this is the the setup and and the
talk today I'm gonna argue that this
kind of classic information Theory with
feedback problem ends up being a very
nice instance of this and what you can
learn and teach on this can really help
you solve uh these diverse set of
problems now in terms of the problem I'm
going to talk about this is the core
problem and this is a part of the AI
Institute work that that I'm involved
the idea is you have a network and this
happens a lot in networks so let's say
even in simple scenarios like
Enterprises you have Wi-Fi boxes people
come and put them on and you pick some
protocol uh to run these at these
networks but there are a lot of loose
parameters whether there are software
parameters that are set in terms of the
protocol performance or hard parameters
like how should you you know sort of
control the beam the the antennas
physically on your your devices and so
on and the way this has been working up
to now pretty much is that you have an
engineer that comes empirically sets
these parameters based on some intuition
but based on some practice let's say
there they could be even distributed
like in this room I come in and set
these parameters maybe somewhere else
around somewhere else in uh you know on
campus it's setting the protocol
parameters all of these become an import
to a function that I that governs the
performance of the network whether this
is delay power latency or whatnot right
and the way it is uh we they hope that
nobody complains if the coverage is bad
they will get you know tickets that come
in that says this room is not working or
whatnot they go back and change the
parameters so it's literally a black box
that governs this performance you set
the parameters there's no close form
there's no derivative so you would like
to empirically optimize this this
function
okay so that's the setting I'm going to
go in more in depth and so I'm going to
show how the methods that we normally
teach and learn here will apply here and
what they have helped us do okay
so um
this is this is among our friends so we
had a course in information Theory it
was the third course in digital com it
was called digitalcom3 and as you can
imagine the number of students in this
class dwindled and dwindled so now I'm
teaching this course so this is the 10
minute plug you make sure I don't go too
excited about this 10 minute plug for
teaching this course sort of void of
communication so it's all now it's
called method information theoretic
methods for data science
um and I'm gonna uh argue that if you
look at these feedback model you can
teach exactly everything that we
normally teach but do it from this
perspective that allows you to look at
machine learning applications much more
succinctly so this is this is my way of
teaching information Theory I'm not
going to talk about all three topics I
uh I start with uh you know Source
coding Channel coding I'm gonna leave
out I'm not going to talk about active
success I know this is my baby not
everybody information so let's just talk
about that first too
um those first two
so I teach entire Source coding as
guessing
right so I mean you can see it it's it's
a simple instantiation of the problem so
I have in the simplest setting I have a
letter of alphabet and the student's job
is to guess what I picked right for that
word and it's simple and they have to
ask me interesting questions and sort of
guess this this letter fast
um and I will force them to only ask yes
or no questions and quickly they learn
that inclusion is is the right way to go
right ask me a question that will tell
you where the word is
right so these are and then I you know
this is binary code words and it allows
me to do sort of uh the the exact same
thing we do in our source coding classes
uh sometimes the students don't see the
the similarity with the model so I kind
of uh like to think about a fixed
Precision number on the unit interval
and I tell them okay so if you want to
guess this number and you know it's a
fixed Precision you'll have to guess its
bits
okay that's and quickly um that will
allow them to
and I can easily show them as a password
guessing right it is easy that these
days with uh you know a large language
models it's easy to to motivate it uh
but it gives them the sense of binary
search binary search you know is
something they're very comfortable with
and I tell them you don't even need to
do it adaptively you can ask for bits
independent of each other and kind of
get the answer and it gives you this
sort of notion of decision tree and then
you can go ahead like I give them the
Shannon funnels you know say okay these
probabilities are not equal so maybe you
want to make your tree a little bit more
balanced in a probabilistic sense which
gives me the channel funnel then I say
let's Design This cheeks simple and we
do you know the the classic proof of
Hoffman to to get the best tree
um the nice thing is uh that will allow
me and also because I have introduced
the bit by bit version it allows me to
do arithmetic codes by saying okay if
you think about Shannon Fano as
balancing your tree
um the sequential way of thinking about
bits arriving one at a time I can hold
back and not ask a question if the tree
is already very lopsided and wait for
the bits to come in to allow me to
spread the leaves so it's really nice
the arithmetic codes and you know it
really becomes very easy to describe it
and of course you can get like very
nicely use the tree structure and craft
it and quality connected to this one
other thing that this sort of view of
sequential uh fat Shannon Fano usually
arithmetic coding gives you is these
Notions that I will talk about in
optimization that comes up these Notions
of optimality right the worst case if I
know nothing what is the worst case
probability distribution what is the
sequence per sequence uh length that you
can do and sort of compare these Notions
of regret and so on that is a little bit
more machine learning that you can teach
here
and and are you I never thought it
before so it's sort of nicely connects
to Universal Source coding and modernism
match which are useful I would argue for
data science students more than we are
used to I also show off this uh this
paper of the Todd where he kind of
extends this to design a brain in a
computer interface by showing lists of
words to
um to a person who cannot type
yes
um David McKay also yes and like exactly
and I want to say
[Applause]
thank you basically showed me this this
is the first time I was talking about
posterior matching she told me about
arithmetic code so that yes I did in
fact I use it but I now have hide it
quite a bit it's not that recognizable
where he was doing it with his stomach
oh yeah
yeah that was my first ASAP
he was talking about Dasher
so um Anna Gilbert said that uh in math
you should show off how old is your
problem and this is my show after
anybody is interested there are the
versions of these guessing games as they
get popular and at the end of the uh of
this section of the class
algorithmically I want them to think
about the entropy of the answers right
as a good heuristic so if things get
very complicated for example for any of
the games and they have SIM they have
signed up to be to do coursework on
these solved word all like you know ruin
your your taste in games by
writing these algorithms and so on
um then I and then it's really easy to
do Channel coding take the same problem
but now add noise so now I'm giving you
yes and no answers you're guessing bit
by bit but I might be flipping the
answers right and then you can say okay
you know what what would you do and the
immediate strategy is every bit repeated
enough so that you can get it uh you
know
um with some reliability move on to the
next bit and so on and so forth
um and quickly you can uh contrast this
so instead of hornstein nowadays I think
a porn scene as a sequential Channel
because they know how to rewrite
probabilities arguably from arithmetic
codes so they can now use Bayes rule to
rewrite probability and keep trying to
balance this code right so that gives
them the the horn scene or generalized
binary search so instead of balancing
according to the half
new balance is according to the media
now the nice thing is that you can
quickly simulate these and you can see
that this is a very bad this repetition
code just every bit by itself your tree
is very imbalanced for a very long time
right after a couple first try and
guessing the bit ninety percent chance
you know what the bit is and you're
asking very wrong questions so they can
easily see that reliability is okay but
the rate is is not does not scale so
they can simulate this and you can sort
of teach them hypothesis testing
comparing sequences of zeros and ones
with a bias and and get nice results one
thing that this way of looking at the
problem gives me that I kind of avoided
was I never gave them Channel coding in
a very rigorous way this is an undergrad
senior level undergrad course and for
channel coding I need a typicality all
these things and 2 to DNR confuses the
hell out of them this way is very simple
they have simulated it they have asked
how many bits this is Precision number
so it has some number of bits and now I
can easily compare the three performance
metric that they have probability of
error and guessing the number uh how
many bits the number has and how many
questions you are allowed to ask and
sort of typically now an R is the
intuitive questions like if it was no
noise you would ask exactly M question
uh log M questions right
um no M questions every bit right and uh
and now I say you don't want to do more
than a factor of that
right and you can do this trade-off and
they can play with the different
algorithms and get this trade off of
like how the exponent of reliability
trades off with rate and this is
something I think is really important
for data science machine learning
students often you hear even in active
learning you hear it's noisy repeat you
know you repeat you get a factor of 1
over Delta or whatever the the machine
learning people call the reliability
right and it just bothers some you know
information here so this is a really
nice way to tell them why you don't want
to just repeat your noisy questions
the questions I have no idea answers
okay I'll stop here I as I promised you
I'll just go now I'm more in depth and
and the problem that we have been
looking at at the optimization is there
any question
yes can you share your lecture notes
yeah
I will share the lecture now if you have
Prezi I can share it on Prezi and I
recommend because that's nice when I
share the PDF it becomes a PDF export
which is very ugly so if you're
interested in that what's the notes from
the classroom
yeah the teaching I.T so I'm working on
the videos and the lecture notes for
that website and um in fact not toss I
just gave this talk and Natasha said
that she's a convert she's done feedback
information this is going to teach some
version of it she does she's not willing
to give up communication completely and
so we're gonna work on on generating so
if anybody is else interested that's my
summer project to make it like maybe a
communal course that was taught in
teaching this one sorry
awesome so sorry about that I I thought
I was very proud of
everybody tells me this President okay
so back to the
back to the optimization setting this is
what we call AI enabled optimization the
idea as I said is that you have a uh
sort of a black box function you can set
the input to this black box function You
observe the value of the function at the
at the set of input
maybe add some noise for example for the
networking you're not going to let it
run forever so you won't see all all of
the performance so you see a noisy
version right so this this problem and
it's AI enabled because the best
algorithms when I started working on
this were called graduate student
discounted like the students sit there
and that the problem comes up in
um for ML community in training and
neural net you have so many parameters
in terms of the architecture as well as
training parameters like learning rates
and backsides and so on and the trick
was that somebody was sitting and
optimizing these hyper parameters when
they were reporting the results and the
idea was can I use AI to set these
parameters uh somewhat more smart key so
we have worked on this problem quite a
bit I'm gonna only report on the the you
know at one sliver because of its
connection to uh to the way I teach
Source coding
um but if anybody is interested we can
talk about various versions of this
problem so this is sort of uh the work
that my
my former PhD student
I put his picture really big in his name
please remember he's brilliant he's the
postdoc at CMU with Aditya ramdas if
you're looking for good faculty uh hires
he'd be he'd be fantastic okay
so
I understand
has on on how well you can do so let me
just give you the mathematical setup
again I apologize if I'm boring you but
this one is I have simplified a little
bit let's say Cube to the D is your
input space and you would like to
maximize this function f but you don't
know the function you don't know its
derivative so it's also called zeroth
order optimization
um and you basically query it through a
noisy zeros order Oracle
so the the framework um I'm gonna show
you is mostly in terms of cumulative
regret much of what I'm going to say
would apply if even if you were just to
identify the point so you take your n
twice and you compare yourself against a
genie that would have known as and would
know the optimizer of this function X so
right so this is the Q
and the first time I heard this problem
I thought this was kind of bogus you
give me a few samples and you want me to
optimize it the function could be this
blue guy could be this red guy one of my
optimizing so it's somewhat ill post
okay so
um different communities have different
conditions on function f to be able to
solve this problem okay so the problem
the problem I'm going to talk about
today is called kernelized version of
the problem which means that we're going
to assume function f comes from a
reproducing kernel Hilbert space okay so
and this space is not to too expensive
so the norm has a bound that I that I
know okay
and the noise is gaussian and I know
again the variance
so the setup is it's called um you know
agnostic
um Bayesian optimization I'll tell you
in a minute why so for those of you who
know okay your chest is that I'm not
going to bore you for those who don't
know let me just tell you a quick this
is just linear sum of kernels the
function comes from a linear sum and the
kernel here I have picked the peaky
kernel this is more smooth kernel so
depending on the shape of your kernel
you kind of control the geometry and
also the norm will tell you how many you
know uh how many functions are involved
how many kernel replicas of your kernels
so this is uh in the literature is uh
called uh Bayesian optimization for the
reason that under this assumption the
problem has a surrogate Bayesian
interpretation so finding the least
Square estimate of the function after n
samples boils down to estimating a
posterior mean of the following setting
the following Bayesian setting I have
function f that I've pulled from a
gaussian process what is the covariance
with zero mean gaussian process what is
the covariance function is dictated by
the kernel okay okay so even though this
problem is an agnostic setting you have
one particular function uh it has a
surrogate Bayesian interpretation which
is I have class of functions
stochastically describe I pull one out
and I optimize that
okay exactly
so for that reason it's called
kernelized agnostic optimism Bayesian
optimization ah this picture I should
have made bigger and it's called Bandit
kernelized Bandit for the following most
of the intuition before we started doing
this work was to gridify the input now
you can sort of think about an arms of a
multi-arm bandit but the arms have
covalent correlation because of
covariance function that is dictating
your your stochastic process so clear so
most of the intuition was for example a
very popular one is called upper
confidence bound uh bound gaussian
process Bandit is just a really apply
your
favorite Bandit um you know uh heuristic
here
and this was the first problem we had
and that's what I'm uh sort of censoring
as soon as I heard it I thought this is
a function the geometry of it should
matter the sort of betting on arms is
likely to be under uh under evaluated
so now because there is this nice
gaussian uh surrogate when you look at
how the performance scales in fact the
mutual information between your
observations and the function picked
from the gaussian the surrogate problem
runs the difficulty of the problem so
the regret is always a function of this
thing gamma n they call it information
okay and it's really nothing but the the
best mutual information you cannot
now for this family of kernels I have
put them up they're called matern kernel
figure and they have a parameter new
that controls how smooth they are when
new goes to Infinity is just gaussian
kernel and when new is uh smaller zero
smaller than one do you get you know
less and less smooth into to get the
exponential at the top and for these
this gamma of n is known
so the scaling as a function of the
dimension of the input oops this
Philippine capital D and new is um is
this
so these are things that were known
now
um
n is the number of samples
yeah exactly the more query you have you
would hope that the regret starts sort
of being controlled
uh zero one to the simple right yeah s
is the the samples that you pick is the
size of that yes
okay
so a little bit of a plug Johnson
scholar and his co-authors in 2017 use a
clever Converse method to provide an
information theoretic lower Bound for
the regress
they said no matter how smart you are in
terms of design of your algorithm your
regret is bounded for mature kernels in
a certain way
okay
and then for many years there was a gap
between disinformation theoretic lower
bound and what the algorithms that were
around could do so for example if you
just do GPU CB or the Bayesian version
GP Thompson sampling you would not even
be able to get uh sub-linear regret for
much of the the parameter space new okay
so there were algorithms that we're
trying to do at least this algorithm
lpgp UCB using polynomial structure by
sub linear and then there were some
other algorithms that were shown that if
the kernel is smooth which in in
um and you can you know you know it's
smoothness Factor so they might not be
smooth but you know it's faster that
it's smooth then uh in fact you can
control it and um there are some Minimax
near Optimal Solutions like
now when we started looking at this
problem just like uh you know so make
the connection back to Source coding
this is a Minimax result it says the
worst function and in fact when you look
at Johnson's proof is he finds the
ugliest function
and in order to test for that function
you have to test it against the ugliest
other compare
competitions so it was a really ugly
setup in in some sense and what we asked
was first of all the lower bound tells
you nothing about how would an algorithm
do if the function is easy
so let's say somehow I know the function
is not as ugly as the ones manufactured
in the Minimax sense how well will you
do and then of course we knew nothing
about how to really think about how good
these algorithms are on real problems
because the upper bounds were also Mini
Max they were just saying how well you
would do on these hard problems
so for example
you would have no distinction between
these two functions which one uh you
know if you're dealt with which one is
easier which one is harder
and it's really meaningful because when
you look at for example
simple convolution neural network and
you want to decide which you know let's
say resolution you would pick for each
layer
it's hard to believe those ugly super
spiky functions that Jonathan was
testing is governing this right for
example you don't want a two course of a
quantization if you quantize too much on
critical you know mid layers you will do
very importantly right so you do need
that you know and this structure was not
was not given
okay so we obtained two results again as
I said driven by this view of worst case
individual sequences and average case
um uh and the the results are this first
of all we found uh sort of an instance
dependent lower bound say if an
algorithm is guaranteed to do a certain
amount on all heart functions can it do
better on certain easy functions right
so that's the first thing and then found
the algorithm that was near optimal and
and in fact
um attached to easier problems so so
this is a pictorial but let me just go
again I promised the Lalita to give you
enough of the meats let me just go a
little bit in more depth as how the
results are so here the lower bound we
we structure it like this we said if I
give the algorithm a bit of Slack say
you don't need to do well on all
functions right equally but on all of
them you at least have to do a0 well
right so don't leave any one of them
completely on its own don't throw away
any possibilities but you're not
expected to do on on the hard examples
maybe as well okay so you give yourself
a bit of slack the question is can you
do adapt to the polynomial structure
around Europe
okay so if you have a polynomial
structure near your optimal that's the
only instance we consider you can sort
of ask yourself what are the instances
that you want to do well this is one
easy one because if you have a
polynomial structure around the optimal
you can sort of say you know I can even
build an empirical estimate for the
gradient and use some something like a
gradient descent noise degree you
understand so what can I adapt to that
can I be you know do well on these
functions
so and we got a lower bound this is
again low insensitive say algorithm
independent lower bound the lower bound
says of course if you give me uh no
slack I have to do very well for all
heart problems then yes indeed you know
it's it's harder the regret is worse
um the same if if the function is really
flat near the optimal you really have to
find exactly where it is that it's
optimal and that's hard right so this is
sort of the the lower bound
that means you pick the pictures are
saying it better so this is my regret
exponent as a function of the dimension
and I'm showing you the uh the lower
bounds I am uh sort of using the label
as if it's policy dependent they are not
policy dependent let me just remind you
we had different classes of policies to
guarantee different regrets right so for
example this policy uh you know Pi GPU
CP uh was providing you know near
Optimal Performance right so in that
sense what we want to make sure is that
of course this policy is doing really
well on everything so in fact it has a
higher uh you know lower bound right
with the regret is worse but it's a
policy in only giving you sub linear
guarantees
and maybe the lower
bar smoothness new uh parameter one and
the polynomial structure exponents is B
uh equal 0.5
and you can repeat this for other things
I want to show you that you know now the
lower bound could also bump up you know
it's not that you always get a better
exponent
okay and then we came up with a
algorithm to match this lower bound okay
so
um the way I presented it it felt like
if I want to get a better performance I
better give a slack on harder instances
so our algorithm is very um it's hard to
compute but it resolves this tension
says there exists an algorithm that does
near optimal all insisters but in fact
does better on polynomial structure so
the exponent is the minimum of the
Minimax exponent and something that can
get better if you have more structure
near Europe
so
it's terrible sorry this is a this is a
pathological you know example that we
build often to to describe the algorithm
it's a whole plus so the maximum is here
and sometimes sorry I apologize I don't
know the lighting is
so you uh the algorithm works very much
uh in in a hornstein scheme it tries to
sort of Bin the areas of the input and
try to get a sense what is the chance
oops
what is the chance the optimizer is in
this half versus in this half and it
just randomly picked the the samples in
those bins and then bins the input
according to your belief about where the
optimal point is and then samples are
very much like the horn scene samples in
areas you believe contain the maximizer
and higher probability and even more fun
it breaks the resolution more and more
around the areas if the difference
between these uh sort of bets are large
enough okay yeah
the posterior updates that you do
exactly so that's where it's very easy
right so you you do all kinds of three
models and stuff like that and that
determines how well you do in practice
yes so two things I can I can tell you
one thing is
um an approximation in the sense that a
lot of the intuition you get from here
you can relate it to some sort of other
weight right and our algorithm was very
much driven by so if you look at
function optimization zeroth order I
don't call because in Signal processing
zeroth order exclusively means you
approximate gradient based on zeroth
order information so I call it the
empirical optimization for that reason
but if you go back and look at these
derivative free optimization methods
early 20th century the word work on
Lipschitz continuous functions and they
were just using the Ellipsis constant to
make the BET as where to go it's like
sort of a climbing the tree based on the
Ellipsis constant our algorithms are
very much driven by those and they have
a decision tree that breaks the input
distribution and search so so our
average is very much related to that
nicer than that we have shown that if
you take a gaussian process you sample
it with high probability its lipsticks
what is its constant is dependent on the
Kernel and the probability that you are
asking so if you wanted to be high 99
lip sheets with a you know and the
kernel is very ugly this ellipse is
constant will be terrible right but it
it in fact it just to answer your
question you can really turn it back to
its geometry if you have better
intuition about how the geometry works
and that's what we do for the polynomial
structure
the second announcer and this is
something that I I really expect
everybody to think about the first time
I heard this problem is the simple
question I am sampling to optimize I
could use the samples to reconstruct
which one is uh you know how much saving
do I have now that I'm only interested
in maximizing rather than reconstruction
worst case result I showed you no
difference to construct and optimize are
exactly the same there are pessimistic
results that says for those ugly
functions if you want to find the
maximizer you essentially along the way
learn the full function for these
instances not so bad okay in fact my um
my current history student Madison Lee
in a sigma processing uh conference that
is coming up in Vietnam is showing a ffd
based solution that really heuristically
works really well on instances that are
you know that have a nice Spectrum so so
in in that sense to answer your question
but the algorithms are literally just
decision tree you know they are just
really really hornstein uh you know if
the noise is there or Shannon's fan or
sequences your asthmaticals okay so this
is the structure this is one D this is
the 2D again it gives you a
multi-resolution of search so the worst
case result I was telling you on
sampling was saying the samples have to
reconstruct the full function so you're
bound by the complexity of the function
and here I'm showing you that in fact I
am zooming in and on most instances I
can have a very good performance for
those functions and just do a sort of a
multi-resolution
okay so the matching with those lower
bounds are these upper bounds and now
you might ask me why is there such a gap
if I was a successful information
theorist my lower bounds and upper
bounds would match and for that I need
to go a little bit more in depth of
describing what those ugly functions and
the the converse results look like so
this is um
this is my function that I would like to
optimize and let's say I have sampled it
enough to identify again the gray
doesn't show here this area is
gray and this area is gray so this is
the crossover area where the function is
in these areas why do I care about this
because these are points that I need to
know if I add a bit of a you know a bump
function this is the the word from the
literature if I add an function that is
nice enough by its kernel that is not
changing the norm much it's still in our
in same rkhs so I added it doesn't bump
my sub-optimal point to be optimal does
that make sense so for me to be able to
with high reliability tell you this is
the optimal I have to rule out this is
not my underlying function
now I have to do this hypothesis test if
it's noisy a bunch of time to to do this
how many such alternatives are there is
how many I can pack these sort of bumps
in this areas in this candidate
competition areas there are sub-optimal
but not too sub-optimal right they're
sub-optimal so they can uh you know they
can
have to be ruled out but not so
sub-optimal that adding this bump
function will not change their fate
now if I pack that area versus I cover
that area I get the lower bound on the
upper back so the the world is not so
nice is that the geometry of these
spaces we have not figured out how to
build these bomb functions to pack and
cover so that's where this gap between
there so I really hope people who have a
lot more experience with this packing
and and covering uh arguments can come
and help help this community solve this
problem Oh My totally long time okay
good I have 50 dots
let me just do history it's good to uh
you know do a little bit so I gave you
the information theoretic sort of view I
want to just uh do a little bit
um in terms of um history of this
problem and the way I have learned about
it and just um in case for the students
I know my students are online so
um the problem of course is very much
motivated by active hypothesis testing
work that Herman chernov did in in early
1950s let me just show you the setup is
very simple you just have hypothesis
that is fixed and it's very nice for
this function optimization you can sort
of think about the identity of your
function as the hypothesis that you
would like to learn
um or you could say and this is uh going
back to this instance dependent you can
say the location of the optimizer is the
hypothesis and you can sort of hope that
the the second one is simpler and you
would like to sample and he showed that
if you keep the hypotheses fixed and you
ask these questions that uh you know you
basically uh test for uh for these
hypotheses you can get an exponential
decay in your in your error and
characterize that best exponent and what
I have learned to like criticize is that
his notion of hypotheses is fixed so the
complexity of the hypothesis doesn't
come into the picture so for my
optimization problem the complexity of
the hypothesis is and that's where I
think information theories we have a lot
to offer is an infinite you know set and
it's really a question of with what
resolution you would like to recover at
that matters in terms of dictating the
other components
um
I'd be remiss if I'm on Berkeley don't
mention David Blackwell's work David
Blackwell and Stein in a independent
work uh worked at the single shot of the
problem and I'm really
um intrigued by their setting
um they said if I have one experiment
and I have the same hypothesis and
hypotheses what is a good experiment
right if I have one shot what do I test
for the results are not so impressed uh
you know interesting the result says if
one of them stochastically degrades the
other one they sort of looked at a
version of conver data processing
inequality that if I have an experiment
that is stochastically degraded version
of another one I can easily throw it
away to give full picture but it already
sort of made a really nice connection to
uh to these methods I.T methods that
we're used to
I myself have been thinking and this is
something that that I have discussed at
nauseum with Mr Max against
on a stochastic
um you know dynamical system view right
so if you take the Bayesian view that I
have some Bayesian belief as where for
example the optimizer is this is a high
dimensional you know belief that I have
to kind of track and these you can sort
of think about
um what do we do in control when we are
dealing with high dimensional stochastic
processes stochastic dynamical system is
often we sort of flatten the geometry
came up with a potential function the
openoff function and sort of track that
and in fact this is the has been used in
the literature on experiment design
linbian degree suggested this idea
um the groups wrote that the the
solution to some Dynamic program for
these problems is really the rightly
uponal function but they all propose
this notion of sort of mutual
information
as coming as expected reduction in
uncertainty and use Channel entropy are
some intuition to solve these problems
so I will wanna and of course the
Praveen who recently passed away again
at Berkeley with John they looked at the
bit by bit problem with feedback right
so they again have some nice decision
theoretic way of of solving this and
now I'm going to end with my
uh sort of introduction to information
Theory I learned about this connection
um from Todd about a work that offer had
done so offer joined in 2008 UCSD and he
had already done a lot of work on
posterior matching for communication
with feedback
and um it sort of was talking about this
meanwhile
um I in young Khan and Michelle vegan we
were looking at the same problem of
feedback in feedback coding but over a
Mac Channel okay so where the the
problem becomes really interesting and
Todd wrote this ICT paper that connected
the dots of seeing from the perspective
of a control theoretic perspective what
the transmitter and receivers are doing
are really refining and controlling the
Bayesian prior right in this setting it
was really simple the questions will
dictate how fast this posterior sort of
Zooms in in the Mac Channel they also
had to communicate with each other how
to coordinate this this process of
coordination so that was really uh that
was really the the point we started with
Michelle looking at the variable land
coding with with a noiseless feedback
and then we learned that that doesn't
give you capacity because we were doing
turn off type Solutions and that's how
this this whole introduction to this
world and I would say and with with
Andrea we look at joint Stars Channel
coding version of this with feedback and
then I should say I'm very indebted to
Yuri and later on with uh to a works at
Victoria where they really could
pinpoint this notion of rage and the
problems that that we were interested in
because when you look at it from
decision theoretic framework even though
deep down into groups work they talk
about Mutual information maximization
all the rigorous analyzes go in form of
exponents and I think that was really a
sort of a change of mind and this notion
of thinking about the the schemes that
information Theory gives you
so
go with that
let me just
uh how am I doing wow okay not too bad
let me just conclude
um
really I I'm hoping to convince many of
you that this sort of esoteric problem
in communication that I think you could
ridicule it right like there's a there's
a noisy Channel
going one way on a perfect Channel going
the other way one is that realistic uh
the core problem becomes very natural in
these sequential decision making because
you remember what you did and you
remember the past so the methods and the
algorithms especially the algorithms
become very useful for a large class of
them in my work uh we have done a lot of
sort of uh quantifying this reduction in
uncertainty if it was Bayesian we had
some methods if it's not Bayesian and I
work with commonly for childhood a lot
and she definitely is not a bayesianist
she's a frequentist really really stunt
so I just cheat I call I do everything
bathing call it weights I just increase
that one the way it really increases and
decrease that so but the intuitions are
incredibly powerful in this sequential
systems and then um one thing that I
have a conjecture but at least
heuristically and
um and anecdotally I should say now here
is simply it seems like any time we need
to do this optimal uh trade-off between
the rate and reliability the complexity
of your hypotheses are too large the
dynamic is really fast one of those
scenarios where rate is important there
is a trade-off that you would like to
see with reliability but it always
hinges upon the availability of some
hierarchical representation so one of
the conjectures that I have is that is
there something uh you know and if you
think about it Source coding all of it
in fact Source coding is the one place
in information Theory nobody actually
thinks twice about using feedback right
Hoffman code Shannon final codes
arithmetic codes they assume feedback
the the funny thing is that you can ask
yourself what if I don't want to do like
what is the open loop Solutions that's
that by itself but in that you have this
hierarchical structure that if I you
know ask these questions you know
inclusion questions I learned tons of
things about things that are all
included in that question right so those
hierarchies seem to be pretty important
for these problems and with that I'll
just stop here
foreign
do you have an example of a problem
where you cannot construct the sort of
hierarchies that you need for feedback
but it seems to me you know like this
notion that you can always zoom in
to kind of refine adaptively kind of
very general
that I was just showing you the pump
functions it ends up being I collect a
sample and I only get information in its
neighborhood because of the covalent
structure
right so somehow I cannot really think
about I'm collecting information so our
trick to create hierarchy is sample
uniformly in that space so that I
learned something about all of it but
it's a bit of a cheat right it's not
like I get one sample and gives me
information in large enough of a set but
that's geometry dependent right exactly
exactly that's what I'm saying is that
it seems like the geometry of how your
queries are correlated will depend will
somehow fundamentally tell you whether
you can get non-zero rate correct but I
mean a lot of the algorithms they start
with kind of okay let's throw White net
and of course and lose to get some first
idea and then you'll be fine right like
a lot of these strategies are two-stage
actually yeah yeah absolutely and I I
you know not only that this whole
assumption that I know the kernel
assumes I have done some pre-processing
to get an estimate so in fact that's
something that is really close to my
heart even simple faster let me tell you
it's a bad limited function and you just
want to reconstruct it we always assume
I know that the limits on the back right
but if I don't
what is it so funny thing is in in in
Signal processing there are some
heuristics lips uh that's these methods
that's a statistics not in Signal
processing
more processing they use it too I think
they redist method several times yeah in
fact what happened is uh
I think I'm almost talking about the
subcult in his plenary he published the
paper on some adaptive sort of a
reconstruction that I think you got an
email from from my coach here Pauling
low a day later saying you've
rediscovered lepsky's method but on the
other hand this is the clearest
explanation of lips
yeah and and for a female processing I
only knew it in the similar processing
context it's very interesting no proof
nothing it just says I'm gonna get an
estimate because of banned by uniformly
stand but it's an optimistic in some
sense I assume it's low bandwidth I
reconstructed take a few extra samples
compare them with my reconstruction
figure out this was a good one there is
there is not much on monotonicity of
reconstructions to know if this is even
a you know at least in in the context of
function reconstruction how much
guarantee you can get but that's also a
really really interesting question yeah
I think there are some things in biasing
optimization where they've learned the
hyper parameters as well and I think
Andreas Crossing had something in that
space would yeah yeah yeah so then
you're going to have to learn hypercraft
yeah yeah it's always yeah yeah yeah so
so
um to plug a bit more on frequent this
side of things uh in in learning theory
there's always work on things like
sequential of automatic complexities
yeah uh little Stone dimensions
so I'm pretty sure that you know one
would be able to connect it to yeah
absolutely I think I I agree I think as
soon as you do sequential no matter how
frequented you take the original your
past samples you would like to build
into some sort of a knowledge and now
not to be too much of a Bayesian
apologist but I would say now from that
point the point of view you would like a
summary of the observations you have had
this is not as expensive as all of them
you don't have to take an ideological
stance
whatever works
exactly exactly exactly
yeah and so so that's why I I always
talk about that uh Blackwell's paper
because it's amazing but if you take
this sort of sequential view it comes up
at some point you have collected samples
now you have knowledge what what should
you do so no one had a quote from black
hole about Beijing
oh yeah yeah
right okay
it was on my committee and uh he yeah
his truck was uh you know the best thing
about patience is
is that they're always right
I mean
yeah he has a famous paper where there
are two basic uh decision makers with
mismatch models and they agree on things
that they can both detect but if they
don't they put zero fires on each other
as well they will never agree right so
no as an engineer I don't take a stand
on this I just use it for some liquid
algorithms
oh thank you so much
we have a half hour break and then we'll
come back with maximum